cientos de policías y militares
desplegados en la selva amazónica
brasileña mientras decenas de Mineros
ilegales huyen de la operación militar
lanzada por el gobierno brasileño contra
la minería ilegal de oro con el fin de
desalojar a los más de 20.000 Mineros
que ocupan las reservas naturales de la
comunidad indígena llanomami los
trabajadores acusan a las autoridades de
atacar al eslabón más débil de la
minería ilegal Aunque pasó lo que pasa
es que no tenemos ningún valor
trabajamos y nos tratan como bandidos y
los que son criminales no son tratados
como criminales
solo presionan a los pobres que son
mineros y ahora estoy pensando no
estudio y no estoy jubilado sabes qué
voy a hacer para sobrevivir
el territorio indígena de los llanomami
cuenta con muchos recursos minerales y
según las ongs es la minería ilegal la
causante de la grave crisis humanitaria
de salud y seguridad que ha provocado la
muerte de al menos 570 menores lo que
está ocurriendo con está ocurriendo en
varios territorios indígenas el
miércoles la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos urgía El Ejecutivo de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva tomar
acciones para la protección de los
pueblos nativos de esta región señalando
a la minería como causante del aumento
de las enfermedades y la violencia en
estos territorios la comisión y redezca
instan al Estado de Brasil a
intensificar sus esfuerzos para reparar
y revertir la crisis humanitaria y de
Derechos Humanos que afecta a la
población ya no mami en concreto piden
que se protejan Los derechos a la vida
la integridad personal la salud la
alimentación el agua y el medio ambiente
así como las tierras territorios y
recursos naturales de esta población Y
es que durante el gobierno del
ultraderechista Jair bolsonaro el número
de Mineros ilegales en la selva
amazónica aumentó con total